thank you
thanks for uh inviting me to the
workshop and then today we'll talk about
a joint work with Mark and old which is
uh which investigates the space
complexity of the coin problem
so what's the coin problem it's you are
given a biased coin which is biased
either towards heads or it's biased
towards tales and you would you want to
figure out which way it is biased using
independent coin purses
um let's parameterize this the problem a
bit so yeah but the bias point you the
bias of the coin is Bice at least Delta
so it either it's heads with probability
at least half plus Delta or its hence
with probability at most half minus
Delta
and then you are given an independent
coin tosses and you want to figure out
distinguish between these two cases uh
these two cases with probability at
least let's say 0.9 or some large enough
constant probability
and um uh now the question is that if
you have an independent coin tosses what
is the bias about what is the max
minimum bias that you can uh distinguish
so uh it's uh it's it's not that hard to
prove using churna bonds and stuff that
um you can distinguish statistically
distinguish uh biases for uh which are
greater than 1 by square root n and and
it's even it's like statistically
indistinguishable when the bias is less
than one by square root n so this is the
threshold above and below which it's
just statistically not possible but as
we know statistical distinguishability
is not equivalent to computational
indistinguishability and um one of the
optimal distinguishers for this uh for
uh solving the coin problem would be if
the majority of the quantos is what hits
you say it was biased towards sets and
if it was tails you say it was biased
towards tails and this is the optimal
distinguisher but then computation for
many natural computational models
majority cannot be computed for example
ac0 circuit which are constant depth
polynomial size circuits or ac0 circuits
with parity Gates or uh some some other
computational models so here now the
because of its connection with majority
function coin problem has find its uses
many users in complexity Theory so to
prove hardness results for various
natural computation models or because of
the because of the there is there is
this inherent Randomness in the problem
that you have a biased point which is
biased with half plus Delta and you are
getting independent doses it's also used
in pseudorandomeness
so uh so the the hardness results and
pseudo random results are for various
computation models for example small
depth circuits restricted branching
programs and recently it was also used
to prove hardness results of streaming
in streaming algorithms
okay so in this talk uh we will the
computational resource that we will care
about for Point uh for the coin problem
would be Memory so so we want to figure
out how much memory is needed to solve
the point problem and when we are
basically imagine this scenario in your
mind you are tossing the independent you
are tossing the coins and then so it you
can think of it as like you're getting a
stream of coin tosses so once you toss a
point unless you store the store it
somewhere in the memory what was the
like whether it was heads or tails it is
lost that that coin toss is lost to you
so this can be you can think of it as
this this model is that the coin tosses
are arriving to you in a stream and then
you want to figure out
um with low memory what is the um
yeah which way the point was biased
okay so uh yeah what uh what is like
some algorithm that and what's the
memory for uh like what can be the
lowest memory you can think of for
solving the coin problem
yeah so so you can solve it in login by
just counting you count the number of
hits you count the number of Tails this
requires login space and then uh now uh
basically after you count you can just
compute the majority and that's like
Optimal uh so counting takes login space
and now the question is can you do
better uh than this
so let's say let's look at some
algorithms uh let's say you want to
solve it in a log k space with case some
number less than n
your first attempt would be what you do
is you keep track of the sum you keep
whatever they mean is you keep track of
the number of heads minus the number of
Tails and then whenever it process K if
it is it crosses K if it becomes greater
than K you output that it's heads if
it's biased towards its and if it
crosses minus K like it becomes lower
than minus k then you say it's uh it's
biased towards tails and now this
algorithm works it can distinguish
points Biz bias One by K
and and it cannot distinguish uh coins
with greater bias than this so this is
like for example if K is square root n
then this basically gives you the
optimal algorithm but that requires
logged in space
and now the question is is this the best
you can do
um is this the best okay space algorithm
can do so in uh 1970 uh Hellman and
cover proved that yes it is the best you
can do if your algorithms are time
invariant so that is basically you have
an automata and then uh you're looking
at like how many number of uh number of
states and automata needs uh to solve
this point problems so if if a streaming
algorithm is time invariant then you
need lock space to detect biases of uh
One by K
uh in this talk we will uh we will look
at time variant uh streaming algorithms
so basically you can do much much better
in memory if you have access to a clock
that means that you know which numbered
coin uh which number toss you're reading
and just this information it lets you
save on memory so one of the motivations
for this like there are multiple
motivations for studying this
computation model in like practical
applications so for example maybe you
just have access to a clock in the
computer and that is an approximation
for what numbered call toss you're
reading or if you are looking at many
um
uh many tasks at the same time then this
is some common information that requires
less information so this is like the
yeah this is a this is so so there are
some various uh uh practical uh
motivations for studying this uh
streaming model which which has access
to a clock and the memory that needs
that needs to keep track of this toss
number which is log n uh is not counted
in the memory needed
okay so this is from uh a practical uh
standpoint that there is this tree where
we were talking currently about
streaming algorithms that have access to
a clock but this these these kind of
models are encompassed by read once
branching programs that would be the uh
that would be the focus of our that
would be the computational model that we
will focus on in this talk so basically
read once branching programs are well
studied computation models in uh
complexity Theory and
um
and this would be
uh and then these encompasses streaming
algorithms with the excess store clock
and we would we want to understand
what how how do these computation models
solve the point problem
okay any questions till now
yeah feel free to ask questions like
from now onwards I will talk about this
computational resource which is memory
and uh this competition model and this
might be new to I don't know people with
mathematical uh uh in in mathematics so
please ask questions
um okay
and then we will see that for biases
greater than equal to n to the minus one
by three uh when you're talking about
streaming algorithms then only order log
log and memory suffices to detect this
biases if it was a time where invariant
then you needed login memory but we are
saying that only log log and memory
suffices to detect biases of n to the
minus one by three and then the
surprising thing is that it is there is
a threshold at this
um this bias that you you need login
memory uh even in this model of
streaming streaming algorithms with with
a clock you need login memory whenever
bias is less than n to the minus one by
three
okay
so let look let's look at what's this
read once branching program
um
so read one's branching program is a
computation model which can be thought
of as an acyclic graph so you have n
times W vertices and the vertices are
divided into n layers and each layer has
W uh W vertices
and uh and then the edges are present
only from ith layer to ith plus one
layer and then when you look at a Vertex
there is an edge labeled zero that goes
to a vertex in the next layer and then
and there is an edge labeled one that
goes to the other vertex this basic this
this transition basically represents
that if you are at this vertex and you
read a zero then you will transition to
this vertex and then if you are at this
vertex and reader one then you will
transition to this one
and um
so so so basically read once this this
this when you transition through the
program this will become like a
computational model so you start at a
vertex in the first layer
um and then uh you you read the input
bits which are let's say n Bits so you
read X1 transition to the second layer
read X2 transition to the third layer
and so on and then finally you will be
in the last layer and then there is a
green node which is the accept state if
your computational path reaches the
green node then you say that the output
on that input stream is one otherwise
you say the output on the that input
stream is zero
so
this is the computational model
and then uh yeah any questions on the
model
you always talk in the same converter
yeah
so yeah so these vertices don't matter
so how is this differently
uh so decision so first of all it's like
a decision tree is a tree this is not a
tree there can be uh different parts
going to the same vertex
yes so like one and zero goes here and
then 0 and 1 goes here so there's like
thousands of width right it's a bounded
with it okay done yeah yeah so it is
a space okay
no yeah I
I so so so okay so this is the real once
branching program now if you have a
space s uh algorithm then spaces
algorithm that works on N input which
then you can construct the read once
branching program that has with uh took
the space and length n so this is
because you if you have space s then you
can look at all the memory
configurations these are two to the s
number of configurations and then uh you
this transition basically represents
like the change in the memory
configuration after you read the input
bit
okay so from now onwards basically a
space s algorithm would give you a two
to the width two to the space with read
one's branching program so whatever we
talked about like log log and memory
would correspond to login with read once
branching programs or login memory would
correspond to n with branching programs
so from now on what we will just talk in
terms of width uh uh yeah and I won't do
these calculations of like converting
the memory uh and width
okay so what is known for Point problem
in ropps
uh so counting uh counting works as we
saw before counting works whenever the
bias is greater than one by square root
n and this is this this corresponds to
width and read once branching program
and then uh uh by by
various constructions it can be shown
that even constant bit read once
branching program suffices to detect
biases of one by poly login
so when whereas if it was
um it was time invariant you would need
at least uh login with but here you're
saying that even constant width suffices
for detecting uh one web poly login
biases
and then uh so I will I will talk about
this construction a bit uh later but uh
to to give a Prelude this construction
uses read one's Boolean formulas and
using similar ideas you can you can get
order login with read one's branching
program for which detects biases of 1 by
n two to 0.3 so already with like known
literature we can we can we can detect
biases on as less as 1 by n to the 0.3
with just login with read once branching
programs
and then what about lower bounds so
lower bounds so there are these papers
that have shown that you need at least
log approximately log one by Delta width
uh if Delta is the bias uh for the
advanced branching programs
and then uh there was uh in in 2020 this
paper showed that uh you need at least n
to the uh on like at least polynomial in
N with when if the bias is one by square
root n
and then the question is what happens in
the middle and then so our paper showed
that counting is basically optimal for
biases less than n to the minus 1 by 3
so you need you need polynomial in N
with three in read one's branching
programs if the
um
if the if the biases are less than n to
the minus one by three but if it is
above that then order log n bit speed
was branching program suffices
the answer is
yeah so it's like log one by Delta
divided by log log n by divide by login
so I think there is there is still like
yeah you can maybe improve a bit on it
like but I think it's tight yeah
um like up to order effect like if you
were considering memory then it's tight
but if you're considering depth it's not
tight exactly
um
okay wait any other questions
okay
I might have been something that is the
randomness
[Music]
so yeah I guess
um it doesn't matter because you can you
can choose one Randomness that works
because uh like it's a non-uniform model
read one's branching program is a non
uniform model so it doesn't matter
but yeah so for now let's assume it's
deterministic
but
[Music]
okay so let's look at uh the upper bound
uh how do some techniques for uh proving
the upper bound
um
so we will look at this Stripes function
so this is basically
so you want R of end so you have n sized
input
[Music]
x n you divide the input into M size
blocks so this is M and then there are
like n by m blocks
and then you do an and on this
on each M size block
and then finally you do an R
so this is the tribes function and you
think of M as like log n
size so basically you are look you're
trying to find a login sized block
that such that all of the inputs uh all
of them uh
um all of the inputs are one
and you want to see if there exists such
a block in this function so basically
you're trying to if the the intuition is
that if there were if the if the bias of
having a one was large then you will
find such a block that like that will
contain one uh login size block such
that all of the input bits are one
so this is a tribes function and
basically
um uh the one of the fact about this
function is that when each bit of X is
one with probability at least half plus
one by login then uh the output of this
Stripes function a is one with high
probability so like with constant
probability
so so this is like it
so one you can think of this as like
basically if if the my bias was uh um if
if these were biased by one by login
it's it's it's amplifying the bias to a
constant probability so it's like a
gadget that amplifies uh biases uh of
the input
and then basically this is also a
function that can detect biases uh that
can detect points uh that have bias one
by login
and now uh that means that it can
distinguish whether the point was biased
towards one or zero okay so why is this
nice because uh because the tribes
function gives you a gives you a bit
three length and read one's branching
program that detects a bias of one by
login
um so let's look at this lead one's
launching program
so again uh the read once branching
program is that you have n layers and
then each because it's with three so
each each layer has three vertices and
then we will color to understand what
what each what each layer vertex in the
layer represents let's color code them
green vertex basically represents that
you have accepted the input at some
point red red vertex basically
represents that for this m size block uh
you are trying to compute the end of the
function and then brown brown represents
that for this m size block the and is
zero so these are the so each uh each D
each layer each layer has three vertices
like this and then you start at a red
node and then if it is a if you keep
seeing one that means that you still
have the chance that the end of this m
size block would be one so you keep
seeing one and after after M side after
m m time steps if everything was one you
say that you are accepting this input
and then if if at any point you you saw
Zero you move to a
um brown colored vertex and then
whenever after M steps uh after M time
steps it's time to now compute the and
on the next size block so you move again
to this red vertex
so note that this this this thing cannot
be done for a Time invariant function so
you really need to know when you are
when you have read M tosses to uh to
make this transition that you need to
compute the and at the next time step so
this this this thing basically gives
um gives the read once branching program
the strength to detect biases of one by
login
um with just with three
no
okay so please
I will tell you what trees
um
okay good
any other questions
okay so as I told you it's like uh you
can think of it this is amplifying
biases like instead of like detecting
one by login if it got a bias of LA
Delta Which is less than one by login
then it just amplifies to login times
the Delta uh bias so you can do
recursive types which will imply a width
W length and read one's branching
program that detects biases of one by
one by poly log so this gives a constant
with read once branching programs
detecting one by poly log biases
yeah so you cannot uh if there is at
some point like the errors accumulate
and then it does not work
um
foreign
Gadget and we are reversing so in the in
the previous few slides the bias uh the
bias amplifying Gadget was the rights
function but now maybe we can choose
some other Gadget uh and then reverse on
it so let's say you we still want the
gallery to be a read one's Boolean
formula then let's say fi is a read
one's Boolean formula that amplifies
bias from Delta to Alpha times Delta and
uh I now I want to say that the actually
the example that I give here is the is
the optimal lead once Boolean formula
that amplifies optimal bias so this is
just this just results in an and or tree
so this gadget is
this
um and uh so it works on four four it's
it's four size that it works on four and
four bits and then uh you are recursing
on on it and basically making an and or
tree and then if this is the property
that if you have you have S size formula
that Amplified Alpha what you can do is
because you in the end you have n input
bits you can you can recurse till login
by log s uh times this so that is the
recursion depth and then
um
uh and then each time you're amplifying
the bias to Alpha times that so you get
the amplification to be Alpha to the log
n by log s which is like which for this
formula gives you n to the 0.306 thanks
Delta so basically an and or tree can
detect biases of 1 by n to the 0.3 uh
yeah
program
[Music]
uh
so now this is just indeed one's Boolean
formula I was talking about a reader's
Boolean formula yet so it's like an and
or three and it's a that's the
amplifying thing but now you use this
connection that reader ones Boolean
formulas can be implemented uh it can be
implemented by read once branching
programs with width equivalent to the
depth
and then because the depth is uh is just
logged in so you now here you are
getting a read one branching program
that is amplifying biases uh uh uh by a
factor of n to the 0.3 uh and uh so so
basically it it solves the coin problem
[Music]
is that the same as the recursive tribes
that you said yeah so so in very concept
right you're recursive on a types
function which is like this end of like
or is bigger and and is smaller size but
here you are recursing on this this
function of RN of end
so it's like basically I'm saying that
you can reverse on any bias amplifier
and Gadget okay and and uh that would be
an idea that we will use so in here our
bias amplifying gadgets are being once
formulas but from to improve on it we
will uh use read one's branching program
as the biosynthesis I guess this is like
tribes with like me plus n equals two or
something right yeah yeah
does it answer your question yeah okay
so so now but uh so now the interesting
part is with read once branching
programs or with login we can even
amplify better with read one Boolean
formulas this is the best you can do but
you need Advanced branching programs you
can do n to the 0.33 times Delta
um it might seem like a small increment
but as we saw its type so that's the
nice thing
okay
so let's talk about
um
uh like this uh so on the previous page
I told you that uh a great one is
Boolean formula can be uh simulated by
the one's branching programs uh using
bit equivalent to the depth so this is a
non-trivial fact uh uh but like it's
it's popular and then let's see a high
level idea for how to simulate a read
one's Boolean formula using a branching
program so so you're given a read one's
Boolean formula of depth B and then uh
basic recursion would be like you you go
you you look at the top and you try to
compute both the the answer to both the
so basically you are storing in this
recursion if you think a bit about it
you're storing a bit for each depth uh
like you will be working on one sub tree
you're storing the answer for the uh for
the other sub tree so you're storing a
bit for each depth so this will
correspond to a d memory algorithm
uh so because you're storing D Bits And
if D is the depth so which corresponds
to two to the deviate uh read one's
branching program but here we are saying
something very strong we are saying that
it can be simulated by just a d plus one
with read one's branching program
uh so how do we do it so
so let's look at look here
um
uh yeah
um so this is this is basically the
Android tree and in the read so a read
one's branching program I am
representing uh length is still n and
for width I'm representing a vertex in
each layer for the for for every depth
of the read one's Boolean formula
so so there is a vertex for the bottom
layer uh bottom uh for the leaves and
then there is a vertex for the uh depth
one uh vertices and store so on and then
how I compute this read one's Boolean
formula using the read one spun
branching program
I look at the first input bit and I am I
am at I start here
so if this this if this input bit is one
then I know that or of this sub tree is
one so I don't really need to read this
uh input
whereas if you were doing basic
recursion you will not use this type you
will still read this input and try to
compute the or finally but here because
it's an and or tree for one answer uh
you don't really care about what the
answer of the next input bit is so
basically you then for the next layer
you move on to this vertex that is like
you are in depth one and whenever
whenever we are at a Vertex which is not
depth 0 we don't care we don't read that
input bit
and then so this is one but but being
this subtree being one does not tell you
what is the uh what is the end of this
sub tree so you you need to compute this
subtree so what this means is that and
you know at what time step you need to
start Computing this next subtree so you
move back to the bottom position and
read this input bit so let's say it's
zero this means that the or of or of
this sub tree still depends on this
input bit and then you read 0 let's say
everything became zero and this end is
zero
now if this subtree is 0 then still for
computing this or you need to figure out
the answer of this subtree and then
again you go to the bottom
and then you keep doing this so
basically I have shown you how to
compute uh how to compute an advanced
Boolean formula by just using bit D plus
one
any questions
yeah maybe yeah I can pause here for
one minute
okay
so again so even if uh you didn't
understand this uh I I want to uh
point out one
one characteristic of this simulation
that is that
for every layer of this of this
constructed read one's branching program
there is only one vertex for which you
are actually going to read the input bit
for any other vertices you don't care
irrespective of what is the next input
bit you are going to transition to the
same vertex in the next layer so only
for one one of the uh only for one of
this uh uh one vertex in in each layer
you actually care about what is the
input bit and will transition according
to that input bit
so this is this is a concept that we'll
Define is called the effective width of
a read one's branching program so the
width of the read one branching program
can be anything but the effective width
is one if for every layer for all but
one node the transition to the next
layer is independent of the input bit
and why is this uh good because when we
recurse on read one's branching programs
with effective width fund then bit
increases linearly with depth instead of
uh exponentially because there is only
one one node that is expanding again and
again so it's a linear growth instead of
a uh exponential growth
just to make sure it's like instead of
doing the recursion in the formula you
do you just convert the formulation
information yeah so that would be
so
that that happened okay so this is the
reason why it grows linearly if you if
you if you convert the read one's
Boolean format to read one branching
program then you can you you have a way
to convert it in terms of like the
effective width is one so if you recurse
on it the depth rule increases by one
but that is just one way of constructing
the advanced branching programs for
solving the point problem
but here I'm saying that like maybe you
now you can develop others read once
branching programs which have effective
with one that that solve the point
problem and then recurs on them because
the need was Boolean formulas can only
take you till one to the and one to one
by n to the 0.3 it cannot improve on
that
um
okay
so this is the
uh this is the gadget that we use uh for
the upper bound the gadget is let R be a
constant then we construct a length R to
the three by two with R to the three by
two read one's branching program with
effective width one such that that
amplifies the bias of Square to Square
Root r
now
um yeah
it's I think these are some constraints
that you wouldn't appreciate right now
but uh but let me talk about another
problem uh from now onwards uh which is
related to this
so
to solve this gadget we look at one
mathematical object and uh and show the
tightness for that mathematical object
and that gives us the bounds for the
coin for the read once branching
programs for the point problem so let's
yeah let's uh let's like let's not worry
about these these lengths and widths and
amplifications yet let's look at this
mathematical objects of sequencing
sequences capturing random works so if I
lost you till now this is uh this this
this part of the talk can be of
independent interest
okay
so here now you we want that we have
this sequence of integers A1 to a l and
then we are getting these random walks
and so you have ran you you want to do a
r bit R length random work and then you
want this this sequence of integers uh
to satisfy some properties
so you want that with high probability
the random walk you that you do like for
example B1 B1 plus B2 B1 plus B2 plus B3
and so on it's actually a subsequence of
A1 to a l
so what do I mean so we write it in this
sequence so it's it's very important
it's a sequence it's not a set so A1 to
a l is written like this and then you
you you do an R length random Works
let's say the first bit is B1 then you
you move to A1 and basically A1 is equal
to B1 only then it's a it's valid and
then you read B1 B2 then you want that
A3 is B1 B1 plus B2
and then you want AI is B1 plus B2 plus
B3
so basically you go on like this so the
random work that you are doing like
wherever wherever we are stepping in the
random work that that sequence should be
a subsequence of this A1 to a l and this
should happen for with high probability
over all uh overall uh R length random
sequences
yeah okay we'll go to the same number no
minus one
so that that cannot happen uh but uh yes
so the sequence so so B1 yeah you should
only go forward
so it's a subsequence so if B1 B1 is
here then then you go to something that
is in future B1 plus B2 and then you
keep on going in quilted you don't
understand
no so I'm saying that AI is a fixed
sequence and then for with high
probability when you take B1 to b r uh
as a random bits it should be a
subsequence of A1 to a n
the sequence for the sums of the
prefixes yeah
and he said it's only valid
everyone is able what's this just no so
that well yeah I think it would be
easier to do it like this so
so these are the random bits now
basically uh I'm doing random work right
so I start at 0 then I do one
one then let's say two
and let's say one
.1 so this sequence 0 1 2 1 0 minus one
this sequence that you get should be a
subsequence of A1 to a l
this is your answer
yeah
okay
so I think once you see an example of
such a sequence it would become more
clear so why is it interesting so now we
want to find the smallest L for which
this is true that you want to that it
should be subsequences uh of A1 to a l
and then you want to find uh the
smallest Alpha which is true
let us give an upper bound there is
there exists uh a r to the three by two
length subsequence a sequence such that
this statement is true so what is the
sequence it's you take minus r minus
square root R to square root r r times
so with high probability a random work
does not cross square root R so there is
always a subsequence basically because
you are doing R times there is always a
subsequence uh for the for for whenever
V1 any of these uh whenever you don't
cross square root or there is a
subsequence corresp of these numbers
corresponding to that random work
okay
so so so this is this is an upper bound
and then this is the fact that we use
um
uh in in our upper bound we say that it
this implies a length and with L read
one's branching program with effective
width 1 and square root are
amplification basically because you are
working with random works you are
getting optimal amplification which is
square root R and uh because
of this nature of this that you are only
skipping forward
um it it gives a read one's branching
program uh with effective width one and
that is what we needed for recursion uh
in this so let me tell a bit about this
uh this reduction if for people who are
interested
foreign
this means that you have
R to the three by two sequence such that
this is satisfied so what you do is uh
you have l
ength
L width
so each each vertex there is a vertex
for each a i
and then ith
layer
means that
you are at a I basically like the random
walk has reached AI
so
so whenever you are at AI only at that
point you need to read the next bit and
figure out which what is your next goal
like what is the next eight AJ
greater than a i that you want to reach
so basically you start with whatever
zero or something let's say A1 was 0 and
then
let's say it set forward to eight three
then you you reach A3 the third layer
and then you read the next bit and so on
so this is effective with one because
only for the for the ith layer uh you uh
only if you are at AI then you will read
the next bit
yeah so so that's why you need bit L you
will have that information that you are
you are jumping several forwards
so so there would be like are you
jumping to forward AJ are you jumping to
forward uh AJ plus one so there would be
it would be stored this information
would be stored because it's a constant
we don't care about this
okay so so the uh is the the the thing
is that it's effective with one and it
needs R to the three by two length
and then why why does now here is where
one by three comes in so now because
one one Gadget reuses n to the three by
two
um inputs
so you because for login by log
are three by two
and then because you are amplifying each
term by R to the half so you get this
total amplification which is n to the 1
by 3.
so this is where one by Three is coming
from because it's square root R and R to
the three by two uh it uses R to the
three by two inputs input bits
ification is uh I think uh yeah you
maybe yeah it's basically it's coming
from that most of the random like it's
anti-considerated the random Works
identity concentrated so basically you
will have this uh
even when you're taking root R steps
the steps that take the the random works
that take two tar steps they should be
in this sequence and whenever you reach
a root R then you have detective bias of
Rooter
either this is optimal yeah
okay
yeah so it's because uh each uh
each each Gadget take R to the three by
two input bits so then you are recursing
for login by log
R to the three by two steps a depth and
then each amplification is R to the half
so you get R to the
half
of this
and then uh
uh yeah you could do the calculation
let's enter the one with three
so you need to recurse
that's why I think that that's the
important thing you need effective with
one so that recursion only increases
linearly with depth
yeah because it just uh
yeah it would it won't be n to the one
by three it would be like some uh maybe
uh
login plus plus some constants like
order of n to the one by three plus
okay great so now the thing is that this
is optimal you cannot do better you L is
is
Omega R three by two
now why is this uh useful to us is
because a length n with W read one's
branching program that soil solves the
point problem for Delta biased points
um gives you a gives you something which
work which has L W Times n and our our
random box of 1 by Delta Square
yeah here like basically there is like
this like square root R by a bias
amplification so that's where there is
this so this means that if you use this
theorem then this means that W Times n
should be greater than 1 by Delta Cube
and then if if the Delta cube is just
like uh Delta is less than 1 by n to the
one by three minus Epsilon then this
tells you that the width should be
polynomial in uh and so it should be
greater than n to the Epsilon
so yeah so so yeah so the lower bound
lower bound can work for uh less than
one to the N to the one by three minus
Epsilon
okay so yeah I think this is uh so this
this proof is uh is a bit involved so
you need to basically uh to just sit a
couple of lines about it so you
basically analyze your the read was
branching program and the probability of
success at each step and then you you
say that the probability of success
basically is a random walk because if
you see a one then you are you are going
towards heads with probability uh uh
with with bias like you are improving
towards uh uh uh you're improving your
probability of success by Delta
otherwise you're decreasing your
probability of sex with minus Delta so
it's like a random work and then you
have to do some uh calculations to say
that the merging in the branching
programs don't help
so basically uh this is the only way you
can solve you can find a read once
branching program uh for amplifying
biases
okay great so in the last slide uh I
want to say a bit about like
why this statement is true uh so we
prove this uh this theorem that L needs
to be at least R to the three by two and
then use it to get a lower Bound for
redones branching program so what you do
is you you take some 0.01 R Points that
that are doing the random work you
basically want to prove that because the
random works are anti-concentrated so
you need a lot of points uh you need l l
is R to the three by two to prove such a
statement you say that you are taking
these these many points and then you are
you are making them do the random work
and then uh you see what are the
distinct uh distinct sums that they will
um they will hit so they hit total n
times R Points because each each point
is doing uh are at our length random
work minus the collisions now because it
is a random work then you can argue that
each two points Collide only square root
R times
so that means that L needs to be greater
than n times R minus n Square Times
Square Root R and first write parameters
of n you get this lower mount
any questions
okay so uh I think uh with this uh uh
and and the last thing I want to mention
is like one of the open problems would
be like if you if you have multiple
passes over uh over this uh coin if it's
like the twice or like uh two pass uh
read one's branching program then does
this threshold still remain like uh or
it does the threshold change uh at which
the low memory algorithms exist
thank you
so the question is that if you have
multiple passes over the stream of coins
then does this threshold hold or not
I think it should hold
because
like if you have like logo and classes
thank you
foreign
so this is like constant but so
basically if Epsilon is a constant then
there is a dump but I think between that
they should be smooth
and then you draw with replacement uh
from the fleeves and each time you see a
randomly so mostly if you see uh you
only sits once but for some free to say
it multiple times like in this model
that's the same password
also I'm thinking about something like a
bit like Google connector but yeah
we're going to do the same but once you
fix the random the sample and then
something for me to randomly replacement
it sort of flexible from a slightly
different than the empirical Delta
because it should be about the same oh
yes
[Applause]
foreign